j'ai des lésions partout sur mon corps
tout ma peau est rongé ados and johnson
est un jardinier américain en fait c'est
un jardinier municipal
ils étaient payés pour désherber les
cours d'école tous les environs des
écoles et il utilisait 500 litres
jusqu'à 500 litres de glyphosate par
jour ça finira par me tuer il est en
phase terminale il a un cancer
extrêmement grave et il a décidé de
poursuivre la firme monsanto et le fait
très très marquant c'est que c'est la
première personne au monde à gagner
contre monsanto le produit roundup où
ranger pro est il une cause majeure du
préjudice physique de monsieur johnson
réponse lice
certains disent que je suis comme david
contre goliath une sorte de gandhi et
tout ça ça m'aide vraiment pour mon
cancer
si dwayne johnson a accepté de témoigner
en exclusivité dans envoyé spécial au
niveau européen
c'est pas parce qu'il avait envie de
parler envoyée spéciale particulièrement
c'est qu'en fait tout le monde lui
demande son témoignage et lui ce qui
l'intéresse c'est pas tant son
témoignage que ce qu'il appelle les
mensonges de monsanto lui il veut qu'on
parle de monsanto papers
[Musique]
c'est hyper intéressant dans le
reportage de tristan alex et qu'on voit
à quel point
monsanto a tout fait pour instiller le
doute et pour faire croire au grand
public que ce produit ne pouvait pas
être dangereux
c'est à dire que la multinationale s'est
débrouillé pour que dans des
publications extrêmement grand public
comme forbes
aux états unis où d'autres publications
scientifiques et extrêmement précise la
plupart des papiers reprennent la
littérature de monsanto dans des papiers
que le grand public a pu lire il ya
jusqu'à 80 % de tout ce qui est écrit
qui en fait a été écrit par la firme
monsanto ce qui est plus effrayant c'est
que ça aussi influencé des agences
nationales de contrôle
donc il ya des scientifiques aussi y
compris des scientifiques de très haut
niveau et qui ont été appelés par
monsanto qui ont été payés par monsanto
pour écrire des rapports et évidemment
le but était toujours de faire passer
auprès du grand public de faire passer
aussi auprès de journaux spécialisés que
ce produit n'était absolument pas
dangereux
tous les scientifiques qui ont été payés
par monsanto approché par monsanto pour
que leurs publications apparaissent
comme des publications extrêmement
sérieuse et qui allait vraiment affirmer
que le glyphosate n'était pas dangereux
c'est scientifique là ne veulent pas
parler ça ça a été extrêmement compliqué
jusqu'à ce petit miracle
le docteur david kirkland a accepté de
nous voir en 2016 david kirkland a
cosigné une synthèse majeur concluant à
l'innocuité du glyphosate dont
l'indépendance est aujourd'hui contestée
il n'y a aucun élément contre moi
étaient dans le reportage on voit ce
qu'on voit un moment un scientifique
extrêmement éminents qui dit que pas du
tout que le rapport qu'il a donnée c'est
son rapport c'est pas le rapport de
monsanto et tristan reix lui prouve que
nous écoute et on arrive et tout parce
que je ne veux plus parler de ça avec
vous maintenant vous me donnez toutes
vos images ce qui est écrit dans le
rapport c'est bien des phrases qui ont
été écrites par monsanto
il semble découvrir devant notre caméra
en attendant cette vaste étude favorable
au glyphosate reste une référence de la
recherche indépendante pour les
régulateurs du monde entier
[Musique]
à la naissance de theo ces systèmes
respiratoires et digestifs communiqué le
médecin qui l'a sauvé a attesté que
l'herbicide avait probablement causé
cette anomalie des eaux a subi une
trachéotomie
depuis il vite avec un trou dans la
gorge c'est pas juste des batailles
d'experts et et des postures on n'est
pas dans la posture
on est une famille avec un enfant qui
souffre tu auras envie de leur dire quoi
si tu pouvais le voir face à toi arrêté
car était devant ouais même c rapporte
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent et m'arrêter